one of the great paradoxes of inventing
at a high level
is that you need to be an expert in your
domain area
and you need to have a beginner's mind
you absolutely need both of those things
the world is too complex to actually
just be a beginner so you know i can't
no matter how inventive i am i can't go
invent a new kind of brain surgery
you have to be a neurosurgeon you have
to already know all there is to know
about brain surgery and then take it to
the next level the problem is for many
people by the time they become
true experts
they've lost that ability to see things
in a fresh way
they've lost the beginner's mind
and so that's another thing you always
need to be stepping back and saying if i
i'm an expert i'm an expert in
launch vehicles or whatever it is
i i need to step back
and say okay
what if i were looking at this for the
first time what would i be seeing and
noticing these are just some of the
things you need to do to be innovative
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get the seven
lessons from elon musk jeff bezos oprah
winfrey and other billionaires enjoy
lesson number two illuminate darkness
with oprah winfrey if you can capture
the humanity of people
if you can just capture the humanity of
the people of the stories that you're
telling you then get that much closer to
your own humanity and you can confront
your bias and you can build your
credibility and hone your instincts and
compound your compassion
you can use your gifts that's what
you're really here to do
to illuminate
the darkness in our world lesson number
three state the mission with elon musk i
think in general if you want to recruit
people
uh that are
you know really talented and driven you
have to say you have to state what the
what's the mission what's the problem
we're trying to solve
and and uh
and and just be clearly willing to you
know pour a lot of blood sweat and tears
into it um and have a convincing
argument for why it matters um
you know there's gonna say like there's
three three major things for
um
you know in terms of motivation uh it's
like first of all somebody's got to look
forward to coming to work in the morning
like if they're
like are they enjoying
the the work itself intrinsically um
that's very important um
and uh
the right work environment can really
make make a big difference there i think
the ideally is that they also feel like
that their rewards will receive um fair
uh financial compensation like that
they're that you know that the financial
rewards are
are are good and fair uh and then third
for the really for the best people in
the world they'll want to know are they
is what they're doing in a matter yeah
like so
uh if they spend 10 years doing this it
will make a difference in the world or
you know will people notice
what matter
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four turn your
passion into a business with richard
branson what advice would you give
someone who's wondering like how do i
find my passion and how do i pull on
these threads and and where are they
going to lead to help us understand how
you got started and how they should
think about it well i think i mean most
um
most people
listening to this show know know what
their passion is and um
and they might it could be a hobby it
could be
you know they could love reading they
could love playing tennis they could
they'll have passions
um and if you have a passion uh
it makes sense to spend a lot of your
life in involved in that passion
and quite often you can turn your
passion uh into a business you can see
um
that maybe there's some aspect of your
passion that people are not doing that
well and um and
you know you can say screw it you know i
i could i coul i could do it better um
and i think all you know if you spend
your life with your eyes open looking
for
um looking for things that frustrate you
looking for a gap gaps in the market
um that's all the business is is it it's
fulfilling that you know filling in a
gap and doing it better than it's been
done by anybody else
um
and
uh
and
and you know it it people who don't have
closed minds will most likely find find
that or find those opportunities
now i suspect there will be
a hundred people who will have come up
with that idea before you um
but those hundred people
um you know won't have had the courage
just to go and do something about it so
um you know so those few people who just
say right you know that i'm going to
give it a go
um that and often end up
you know being being successful lesson
number five make a difference with bill
gates you have decided that your
foundation would focus principally but
other things as well but principally on
health in africa
and k-12 education united states is that
right yeah health for of all the poorest
but africa's paradigmatic so how did you
come to those conclusions that those
were the two things you wanted to work
on as opposed to everything else
we talked about it a lot so that's the
decision that melinda and i
made we wanted to take the greatest
injustice in the world something that we
could make a huge difference in and
that's health now we broaden that a bit
by doing agriculture and sanitation some
other things
and then we wanted to take
a cause that would
help the u.s
be as strong as it could and in that
case trying to help improve
educational opportunity is our big thing
lesson number six build a warrior
culture with grant cardone how do you
build a business with a strong base of
operations you talk a lot about sales
and marketing
but how
how do we do it that sales and marketing
go into a strong base of operations and
process
how do you go what advice would you give
an entrepreneur to build that strong you
need a strong culture you have to have a
strong culture and the culture starts
with the leadership right so
if
i'm trying to teach and this is what
happens in big companies and and causes
big companies to fail is the ceo often
is not really connected to what's
happening on the ground
and um it's one of the reasons we've
been so successful in america
crowdfunding yes against conglomerates
culture is the leadership calls out the
people around me keeps everybody sharp
exactly or you have a culture where
everybody's asleep exactly you have
culture either way it's like what
culture do you want do you want
warriors and fighters and acquirers and
people that are hungry and never
satisfied or do you have a a culture
we just left the meeting and they're
like we got problems here people are
satisfied
or
and not working hard enough
there's a handful of people that are
extremely aggressive here but for the
most part the the woman told me most
people are just making excuses not going
to the next level not taking the action
saying this or that about this or that
that's the reason why this or that is
this this or that right and and so you
got to build a culture of no excuses
means you got to bring hire people and
get rid of people
we met with some real estate agents
yesterday they hired a thousand sales
people
for this project they're doing 10 10 10
billion worth of real estate to sell
they want me to sell it all
i said yeah i can do that
so i'm sorry and and um
a thousand sales people now they're down
to a couple hundred i said dude you
don't call you you you have to get a
strong culture
he's like we don't have any culture i
said oh yeah you do you you on board
people and then you don't train them and
educate them and they make sure that
they're excited and keep with them you
can't go to an event for three days get
excited and think it's gonna last three
weeks later it's not
that's got to be instilled into the
culture
you know you look around these buildings
the way these buildings there's
reinforced steel there's concrete
there's glass there's blue like some
something's holding that thing together
the birds where i'm staying holding it
together
long after it's built and that's what
has to happen with management and
ownership and lesson number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is change your mindset with
tillman fertitta you know what's funny
is i've never had a burnout ever i've
been and i've been i've been going like
this for for uh
a long time
decade 35 40 years even i mean i started
going at it in my teens hard and and
i never had that burnout and i think
that's kind of a state of mind that uh
if you're going to get burnt out if you
want to get burnt out but but
i always was going like this and so i
just kind of felt like i'm so fortunate
to to
have it going why should i ever let the
momentum go the other way
and then of course you know one of my
great sayings is there's positive people
and negative people and and when you're
with a negative person or you're with a
positive person one of two things is
going to happen the negative person is
going to make the positive person
negative or you're going to take the
negative person and make them positive
so i've always paid attention to who
i've always been around also and and
i never wanted to be around people that
didn't want to achieve right and
but i've never even come close to saying
i'm done i'm burned out i'm not doing
this anymore
the single greatest thing that you can
do to improve the quality of your life
is to take responsibility for it no more
blaming your parents or the country or
the government or your family or your
community or your education no more
blaming other people it's you
it's you it may not be your fault where
you are right now but it is your
responsibility alone to fix it you
didn't pick where you started but you
can choose where you end up
it's up to you so i remember growing up
my parents were very hardcore in
education you see my parents behind me
here
i'm eight or nine years of my parents
and we were a middle-class family we
weren't poor by any stretch but we also
you know we're not rich
and my parents invested
basically everything they had into our
education they put us all in the private
schools and taking three kids into
private schools was a giant chunk of the
income that they made and so we didn't
spend money on a lot of other stuff you
know i remember driving into my school
and all of my all of the friends all the
other people at the school
had all these fancy cars that when
they're when they turn 16 they're you
know given a mercedes or bmw from their
family and you know my family had a
reliant k car that kind of
made a bunch of noises that as i came
into to the school that was i don't know
how however many years old just because
my family you know prioritized
education and and we were playing in a
league that was
maybe above
our means but they valued that so much
and then we took a hit on other things
and i remember used to get made fun of
for the car
and i never went on the vacations that
they went on and i didn't have the fancy
watches and all that other stuff and
there was one friend of mine
who was kind of in a similar boat where
his parents
you know weren't making a lot of money
invested everything that they had into
his education too and so we quickly
became friends as the
uh as i guess the poor kids
at the school but it's funny now because
i never blame my parents i i'm super
grateful for the opportunities i mean
why i have them up on my wall that they
invested so much and that they cared and
it's on me
like if my business doesn't work out
it's not their fault
right up until you know you can
potentially move out i don't know what
age you want to say if it's 14 15 16 18
but after a certain age you're an adult
i need to take responsibility for your
life
i can't be here at held am i now 39 i
can't be 39 blaming my parents like it's
my fault
if i'm not successful it's on me what
happened when i was six years old
doesn't matter anymore no it's on me
like and there might have been some
crazy stuff that happened to you right
but
you're allowing it to happen to you
every day you're allowing that story to
come up and hurt you every single day
now it's your choice you don't have to
end up in the same spot that you are
right now
it starts with you stopping blaming the
people around you
and what's been an amazing full circle
moment is a lot of the people that i
went to school with a lot of people who
are gifted those mercedes and bmws you
know when they're 16
they're now coming to me and asking for
help
now i'm i'm more successful than a huge
chunk of them they want to start
businesses and they don't know how to do
it they're asking for help and reaching
out
um it's a pretty wild experience because
i almost went down the path that they
went in terms of getting the jobs but i
became an entrepreneur and that can
happen to you too
right all the people who
who you're jealous of all the people who
might be giving you a hard time all the
people around you who
aren't chasing their dreams down
you might end up being an inspiration to
them but it starts by you being an
inspiration to yourself it starts by you
taking accountability and responsibility
and saying i'm gonna go make my life
better than what it is right now so how
do you do it i'm gonna give you three
steps let's go step number one is figure
out what do you want what do you want
like what do you want what do you want
out of life what do you want your life
to be what do you want to do
who do you want to be what do you want
to be doing on a regular basis what's in
your calendar like what do you want what
do you want i want to solve the world's
biggest problem
try saying that on the street
right it's crazy what do you want to do
what do you want
even though the people around you may
not understand it chances are they won't
chances are the thing that you want is
not what your parents and your family
did it's something totally different
it's an opportunity that didn't exist i
had a guy on my twitch stream yesterday
uh league of legends online he was
telling me i wish i was born a couple
decades earlier because i would have had
a comic store
but now you can't make money at a comic
store and i want to be financially
independent you want to be financially
independent dude you don't want to be
born two decades ago
the guy who was born two decades ago
barely had any tools available to be
able to become financially independent
people who owned comic book stores two
years ago were not financially
independent you're living a really
meager life i mean you can you can be
independent i guess not having to work
for somebody else but you're not you're
not taking massive vacations you're not
making a lot of money
but now
the amount of opportunities the fact
that that you could be sitting here
playing a video game and making money is
crazy did not exist 20 years ago so no
don't go back and wish you were born 20
years earlier so you can open a comic
book store you have way more
opportunities right now to be
financially independent so what do you
want figure it out number two is
eliminate the negativity so you want
this thing you want this life you want
you want these resources at your
disposal you want to be doing these
things there's a lot of people including
the voice in your head there's a lot of
people saying you can't do that you'll
never do that you're not good enough do
you know where you came from you know
what your education is you think you
think you can go do that are you crazy
you nuts you can't do that
start to shut it down
start to eliminate the negativity and
you know by how you feel
if you are this is especially i think
about people
and the resources that you're consuming
so the media you're consuming right
people and what you're consuming so
videos that you're watching uh you know
books that you're reading although
chances are there aren't that many super
negative books but think more videos
you're watching i guess series you're
watching where you might lose your time
and the people around you where you feel
worse about yourself where you feel
lower energy than when you went in or
you're just escaping your problems
instead of actually confronting them
right you want to eliminate or at least
limit exposure access to it now maybe
that's your mom so maybe you don't talk
about some things with your mom now
maybe you shut off that kind of side i'm
not saying you need to eliminate your
mom from your life although for some
people that's that's honestly the best
thing and people have done it and then
exploded but at least limit access to
certain topics eliminate the negativity
and then step number three is fill the
void with possibility
so you've eliminated access you're not
hanging around with your friends who are
always complaining to be negative you
stop watching the shows that don't teach
you anything that are mindless
entertainment you stop talking to people
about the things that you know they're
going to just berate you for and never
support you on great so now you have
extra time we're going to spend that
time on
inject yourself with possibility
surround yourself with people who are
doing amazing things that could be even
in the form of videos could be this
maybe the inspector videos you need
every day awesome i'm humbled to be a
part of your journey maybe it's the top
10s maybe it's my main channel maybe
it's other videos other creators maybe
it's going to events maybe it's hanging
out at different meetups and meeting new
people right there's lots of different
things that you can do
but the goal is to fill that void in
your time now with possibility because
the more that you're around people and
ideas that make you feel bold that make
you feel like it's possible that crazy
idea the what do you want back in step
one that you feel that it's possible
that you can't do it that
you that might actually be attainable
that seed of hope is everything because
whether you believe you can and you
can't you're right the people around you
chances are telling you that you can't
do it
and you need to switch the narrative you
need to change the story by injecting
more possibility into your life how did
you get through like tactically to a
sale in the encyclopedia world like
people don't want to hear from you so
like how do you overcome that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was out for three and a half years and
the way it worked in those days it was
commission only so the way it worked is
you went for an interview they told you
all you could possibly make off
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing well when you got in the
field you remember parts of it you knock
on doors you're not quite sure of
yourself a lot of doors are closed in
your face but what happens after a while
you start getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other
salespeople what you see what you do
what did i say
uh so let's say knock on 100 door skin
into one give 10 presentations to sell
one book but then when you get better
and better at it through your
experiences and losses along the way it
sharpens you up where all of a sudden i
got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order commission only but i believe that
i could do that i believe that colleges
were the best set of books because a
high school student could read it it
wasn't like a college manual you had to
read and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe that
what you're doing is good is going to
benefit somebody and you learn as you go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people know these things look
someone the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're on or
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes or their eyebrows looks
like you're looking over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile is the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes people change and so
at what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for what was
the point where you guys said hmm like
let's do this like what was the well we
were planning to do it because i knew
the business i was in marketing sales
and structure and had connections with
uh product development
and i didn't do hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world
very advanced in what he did however he
didn't do business it was the perfect
combination
guys together we're just the best of
friends and we knew we could do it uh
obviously we started out with nothing we
made the decision let's just let's just
make this happen and as you will see in
your guests we'll see when they look at
good fortune the movie and it's on
itunes it's on amazon all those when
they look at it it's a whole story of
starting in america with nothing a
couple times and making things happen
because of what you believe in but the
important thing is even we had nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first coming to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state wow or other things we do not
shake your hand to that sure you betcha
but i applaud you for that that's
we felt a little bad i i certainly i did
about leaving the university
when
uh i thought very interesting work on
artificial intelligence was really on
the verge of taking place and
symbolically proving programs were
correct ironically now you know it's
taken a long time the rate of progress
which is hard to make numeric in both
those areas has been quite modest i mean
we haven't gone backwards or anything
but a.i
has turned out to be a tougher problem
which is is fascinating and now there
there are some interesting advances and
likewise symbolic
type things there are some now advances
so we thought we'd miss
uh being more at the center of those now
through at least funding microsoft
research we get to
have some
level of involvement in that
one of paul's ideas was to build a 360
emulator that was the dominant mainframe
of the time use bit slice
architecture to just you know blow away
the pricing on
mainframe computing but we decided that
was kind of boring uh compared to
personal computing a company came along
about five years later two pi and did it
uh they didn't do the software piece
right that's why they failed uh because
we still think it was a good idea but we
didn't have anything even close to hey
let's build the computer that we want to
use that we want to have as a tool for
our own
uh messing around and communication and
creativity that that kind of got at the
center of our thinking even from
the early days when i was young
i had to read the world books sort of
alphabetically
and it didn't have any videos you could
click on and it was
you know it's weird to learn things
alphabetically it's kind of hard to
create quite the same framework as you
can with all these great online
materials
uh and so i think
the empowerment now you know the
opportunity to see what's going on
whether it's in fields of science or uh
in places that are far away including
else most need it's never been so great
it's a wonderful time to be a student
now software in terms of letting us
simulate things whether it's scientific
phenomena or social phenomena
it's getting
better and better and so i think almost
any major that you have nowadays
understanding you know what software how
it's going to change those activities uh
is a key part of
of being at the cutting edge and i would
say reading
is the strongest
signal for success in the future that
i've ever seen it is the strongest
strongest strongest i got my first job
in radio
uh when i was 16 years old because i've
been broadcasting since i was 16 years
old but my first job i got because i was
a great reader when you are a great
reader you can articulate and speak
and command the english language in ways
that other people cannot and people
think you're a lot smarter than you are
lots of times because you're a great
reader have you ever met a person who
was a great reader when they were young
who was not successful
you never never it is the absolute best
foundation ever
in life there's a friend of mine who's
got a great saying about creating a
company
which is
creating try trying to build a company
and have it succeed is like eating glass
and staring into the abyss
so i mean what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then then reality sets in things don't
go as well as planned customers aren't
signing up the technology or the product
isn't working as well as you thought
yeah um and um
and then that can sometimes be
compounded by a recession
um and uh
it can be very very painful for several
years um
so i think
um
frankly starting a company
i would advise people to have a high
pain tolerance
how aside from making great products how
do you get people excited about tesla
there's a lot of people i know and that
i talk to who are just intrigued and
interested and excited about tesla as a
company the thing i really focus on at
tesla is like we really put all the
money into an attention to trying to
make the product as compelling as
possible so um
because i think that really the way to
um sell any product is through word of
mouth so if if
when somebody gets the car they really
like it they and and actually the key is
like to have a product that people love
um and and generally people
you know if they're a party or
tour friends or whatever um you'll talk
about the things that you love
but
if you just like something it's okay
you're not going to care that much but
if you get the reactions from the highs
and the lows so you got to make sure
people really you're going to
you're going to talk you know and and
then that will generate work during word
of mouth that's basically how how our
sales have have grown like we don't
we're not spending money on advertising
or endorsements or
uh and um so anyone like buys our car
they just bought it because they they
like the car and you know it's like it's
genuine i came across the fact um so
this is 1994. nobody has heard of the
internet very very few people and i came
across the fact that the web world wide
web was growing at something like 2300 a
year this is in 1994 and anything
growing that fast is even if it's
baseline usage today is tiny
it's growing so fast it's going to be
big
and so i looked at that and i was like
there's got to be i should come up with
a business idea and get you know on the
internet and then let the internet go
around this and we can keep working on
it and so i made a list of products that
i might saw online and i started force
ranking them and i picked books because
books is super unusual in one respect
which is that they're more book items in
the book category than there are items
in the other category there are three
million different books active and in
print around the world at any given time
so my my the founding idea of amazon was
to build universal selection of books
the biggest bookstores only had 150 000
titles and so that's what i did and and
i you know i hired a small team we built
we built the software i moved to seattle
and when you told your parents you're
going to quit the esha where you're
successful making presumably a fair
amount of money yeah and you told your
wife mackenzie that you're going to move
across the country what did they all say
they were immediately and reflexively
supportive right after they asked the
question what's the internet by the way
getting it wrong isn't that bad that's
the other thing
when when we make mistakes and we've
made doozies like the fire phone and
many other things that just didn't work
out i can i could we don't have enough
time for me to list all of our failed
experiments but the big winners
pay for thousands of failed experiments
so you try something like prime and it
was very expensive at the beginning it
cost us a lot of money because what
happens when you offer a free
all-you-can-eat buffet who shows up to
the buffet first
the heavy eaters
it's scary it's like oh my god did i
really say as many prawns as you can eat
and um
and so
that is what happened but sure but
surely we could see the trend lines we
could see that you know the diff all
kinds of customers were coming and they
appreciated that service we are not a
company that
normally china call we call ourselves a
company running a platform a company
that is running an ecosystem
we are almost everywhere people say jack
you know you are in the b2b and b2c and
you're calling c2b on a finance and
online payment logistics cloud computing
you are everywhere
not because we're greeted not because we
want to do it because we have to do it
if we cannot if we do not do it china
e-commerce in the years will collapse
i remember nine years ago when i started
the alipay people say jack don't touch
the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison
and i we taught ourselves if we don't do
it
the china e-commerce were always like a
like a chat
room everybody said it's a good thing
and yeah i don't pay you don't get the
things so i say well put me in the
prison let's make sure that alipay the
payment solution works and people say
the payment solution is such a stupid
idea it's an escrow service
i pay you hold the money and you get the
things
you pay the money if you don't get the
things you want return the money they
said it's a stupid product
and i say as long as they solve the
problem i like stupid things you know
let's make stupid things smart keep on
improving every day i never thought it
would be successful i never thought
we could survive for 18 years
and then we made it
the only thing that today we should do
is share the experience and know how
especially share the mistakes
suffer with others
my
thinking is that
you guys remember
if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they make
don't listen to that
there are a lot of reasons behind it
just
like
i remember the first time harvard
business school came to us say jack
we want to write a
case study for you
yes yes 2001 or 2000.
they came they spent one week and they
write a report and i read no i said this
is not me
and this is this is you that's no this
is not us he said this is you so the
makeup is signed
and the case study go up and they start
to teach in a lot of universities the
next five years they invited me to go to
the case study and they always find a
competitor of my company and if after
every
case study alibaba would die that
company will succeed
all the students agree and actually
every five years all the competitors die
we still survive
so how can you study this kind of a
successful story
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are you will
encount these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come this suffer comes
you know how to deal with it
how to face it
i
i the book i want to write
if i
if i want
if i can
it's alibaba 1001 mistakes
this is the most treasurable
things warren is probably the most
rational person i've ever met charlie
munger would be a close rival
and charlie became a man that warren
depended on heavily
and i think his first experiences in the
discarded cigar but era convinced him
that it was not exactly where he wanted
to be
he'd made so much money for so long
doing what he'd been taught by ben
graham which should buy these very cheap
stocks
if they were cheap enough he didn't care
it was a lousy company and lousy
management he knew he was going to make
money anyway just because of the
cheapness
charlie munger has had a big impact on
me in
moving me toward looking for wonderful
companies at fair prices rather than
fair companies at wonderful prices
and that was enormously important
because it enabled berkshire to scale up
in a way that would have been impossible
to do otherwise
[Music]
[Applause]
we were metal partners right from the
moment we met
i want to know going back 50 years what
it was like when you first met warren
well i thought he was a prodigy
and i got a lot of criticism my wife
said why are you paying such enormous
respect to that young man with a crew
cut who won't eat vegetables
he's ungodly smart he's got a much
broader intellect than i do
and he's magnificent at being able to
condense important ideas into just a
very few words
if you're not interested in the economic
scene right now
you're mentally dead
charlie has no tax all right let's talk
a little bit about bankers charlie on
friday compared them to heroin addicts
yeah well that's colorful charlie but i
would not have chosen that
i once wrote of him that when they
handed out humility he didn't get his
fair share
the ideal way to run a headquarters is
to have
one man
preferably over 80 sitting in an office
by himself
anything else is pure fruity
he's always honest than what he tells me
so i i listen to him
we never had an argument
we just
we just kind of roll with it easily
suppose warren doesn't want to do
something that i would have done
and suppose that happens four times over
40 years or something
what difference does it make to me
net the record is working out fine
what are the key indicators you look for
within companies before making an
investment
well i look for something that does give
them a motor rob
we have a company called sea's candy out
on the west coast these candies box
chocolates
if you give a box of sea chocolates to
your girlfriend on the first date and
she kisses you
we own you you know we we can raise the
price tomorrow and you'll buy the same
box you're not going to fool around with
success so
the key there is the response
you do not want to go home on
valentine's day and say to your wife or
your sweetheart
preferably
they're the same person you don't say
here honey i took the low bid it doesn't
work
price is
to a degree is immaterial if you've got
a economic castle people are going to
come and want to take that castle away
from you and you better have a strong
moan you better have a nightmare castle
that knows what he's doing but if we've
given the world a voice look at what's
happened in the last year you've had
elections in the last years elections
manipulated hate speech that's gone
viral and turned offline um it certainly
seems like this mission
has been accomplished in many ways and
and there's a whole new set of problems
that perhaps you guys didn't foresee um
and now we're in a very complicated
place where there's not an easy solution
yeah there's these are complex issues
that you can't fix you manage them on an
ongoing basis
but
look
do you think that the world is better
with everyone having a voice and having
the ability to express their opinion um
and being able to connect to who they
want i don't think we're going back to a
world where there were just a handful of
gatekeepers who got to control what
ideas get expressed
and even if we could well i'm trying to
make it so we're not i mean that's why
um making it so that we're building
these independent governance mechanisms
and things like that are really
important and that's that's work that i
that i really care about um
but i think that the world will keep on
moving in this direction
people will more people will keep on
getting a voice
i think that that's good and and and i
think there are certainly going to be
issues that we need to work through over
time but i think that while we are doing
that we can't lose sight of all of the
really positive things that are that are
happening here as well
not just in terms of communities and
people being able to to connect with
with groups that are really meaningful
to them whether it's around a disease or
or a community around veterans that they
wouldn't be able to connect to otherwise
but even if you just think about the
economic impact
of what we're doing
you know we serve 80 million small
businesses around the world
about half of them have told us that
they're hiring people because of using
our tools and that without facebook and
the tools that we that we provide and
they that their business would be
significantly smaller and they wouldn't
be hiring as many people as they are
so you know a study came out the us
economy added about four and a half
million jobs over the last year
if you just look at like what people are
telling us the small businesses who use
our tools
we've directly been able to contribute
to creating many more jobs than that
across the world so i think that this is
the power of giving people a voice
giving small businesses giving
communities giving everyone everywhere
the ability to connect with the people
who who they care about and get their
opinion across and giving everyday
people the power that previously only
big companies would have had so that's
it the world is going to go more in that
direction and i think by and large
that's a good thing so i'm really proud
of the work that we're doing on this and
we there are big issues and i'm not
trying to to say that there aren't that
we need to work through but i i do think
that sometimes you can you can get the
flavor
from a lot of this from from some of the
coverage that um
that's all there is and um and i don't
think that that's right either we need
to make sure that we address these
these questions these are really big and
important things for the future of our
society and the future of the internet
but we also need to keep pushing in the
direction of empowering more people you
know to me entrepreneurship
is about creating change
not just creating companies
and you know the most effective
entrepreneurs that who i've met
care deeply about some mission and some
change that they're trying to create and
often they don't even start because
they're trying to create a company right
and you know that's how i think about um
you know my connection to
to all of us here is you know i was
getting started i um and i want it i
care deeply about giving everyone uh a
voice right and giving people the tools
to share everything that they cared
about and
uh bringing
a community together and you know it
started small and in one university
and i didn't think it was going to be a
company at the time as a matter of fact
i was pretty convinced that at some
point someone would build
something like this for the world but
uh you know i thought that that would be
some other company that you know already
had thousands of engineers and was used
to building stuff for hundreds of
millions of people around the world and
you know what ended up happening was
um
you know that no one built it right so
we just kind of kept on going right i
mean people said it each step along the
way
um
you know what you're doing
all right maybe
college students like it but no one else
is going to like it and you know there's
not going to be any money in doing this
so all right so you only really do it if
you care right if you're passionate
about doing it and then it started
growing and people said it would be a
fad and it would never be a good
business but you know you keep going
because you care
not because you're you're trying to
create a business
um and
you know then there was the shift to
mobile where people thought that you
know it wouldn't be a sustainable
business and
um you know it through each of these
things you the
the entrepreneurs who i think build
things that last for a long time keep
going because they care fundamentally
about the change that they're trying to
create in the world
and they're not in it just to build a
company i feel like hustle is
the willingness to work really really
hard and then also your willingness to
get the job done like um kind of
navigating and doing what it takes
and um
and so
i i yeah i've there's so much about my
journey where i was like i am not going
to let the outcome or my success
be contingent on other people as much as
i can control it help it navigate it i'm
going to so um
so yeah in the beginning especially
still now i mean obviously i'm hustling
i'm like at the at this where i am now
and i'm running around the airport
asking people to follow me on instagram
you know uh i just feel like it's innate
in me also to a degree um but
the uh in the beginning ex like there's
a few examples that come to mind you
mentioned that i paid my i called my
friends and asked them to go buy spanx
and i wrote everybody checks and sent
them a check
because i needed to drive momentum and i
had no money to advertise so i'm like
this product is going to sit on the
shelf so i need to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that my product was in the
sleepiest part of the department store
it was back in the corner and nobody was
going there so then i immediately
went to
target and i bought
envelope dividing dividers that you put
on your home desk and i ran around
neiman marcus and put them at every
register and i put spanx in them and
then i walked away
and
neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and um and i did
that because i had to get my product out
of the department and because i did that
women in shoes started buying spanx and
women in contemporary
and
those decisions made such a big
difference and by the time somebody
figured out that nobody else had
approved it because that you know
everybody thought somebody else approved
it
um
it was so successful that the head of
neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it but i
cold-called neiman's sacks nordstrom
bloomingdale's qvc i was out on the road
and i think a lot of entrepreneurs make
the mistake they think once you get the
order you're golden and that couldn't be
any farther from the truth once you get
the order that's when the real work
starts i was absolutely determined to
ensure my own success and i think that's
what it takes i didn't want my success
to be contingent on anyone else having
to sell this so i hit the ground running
and i went from department store to
department store and i would do morning
rallies at the store where i would
gather people around well the store
manager said sarah you know you can do
it with the hosiery associates well i'd
travel all the way to arizona and
there'd be three hosiery associates so i
quickly was like i got to get the whole
store at this morning rally so i would
go into the entrance before the store
opened like a neiman's or a saks or a
bloomingdale's and i would run around
and introduce myself to every employee
setting up their station i'd say hi i'm
sarah and i would try to convince them
that it would be worth their time to
come see my morning meeting and i got
everybody there i had taken the oprah
clip and the a little bit of local press
i'd i'd received and put it on a video
and
did that in my morning rally
and it was such an important thing that
i was doing i inadvertently was building
a sales force that wasn't on my payroll
and they all across the country became
my biggest advocates for the product and
started selling it on behalf of spanx
and me can you take me back and tell me
how you've done this larry you're you're
the godfather of technology you founded
this company you're still thriving
you're still coming with all these
innovation things and i could see how
passionate you are you're beating
everybody um
and you came from such humble beginnings
grew up on the south side of chicago
dropped out of college now you have
collections of cars jets private homes
owning the island of of lanai tell me
how you did it
well i think i think my favorite line is
i had all the disadvantages necessary
for success you know uh
when you're raised on the south side of
chicago you probably want to move
someplace nicer
and
i think if it doesn't kill you and makes
you stronger so
i've always been very ambitious i've
always been very curious
uh
i was you know
moved to silicon valley right out of
right after i dropped out of college and
got a job as a computer program i
learned how to program when i was in
college and i got a job as a computer
programmer and bummed around yosemite
valley teaching rock climbing and and um
and
leading river river river trips uh
during my early 20s but the way i
supported myself was as a computer
programmer
and i got involved with more and more
interesting and complicated
computer projects and decided to start
my own company throughout my 20s i
continued experimenting trying different
things racing bikes and boats and
constantly changing jobs
it didn't take me long to discover
that the most interesting and rewarding
programming jobs were found at a cluster
of companies located south of stanford
university in north of san jose
silicon valley was in its infancy
i was still in my twenties when i went
to work for my first silicon valley
startup
amdahl
where we developed the world's fastest
mainframe computer faster than anything
ibm had
next stop was ampex
where we built the world's largest
digital data storage system
then on to precision instruments
where we built an even larger data
storage system this time using lasers
i was the vice president in charge of
software development
it was all
very cutting edge and challenging and
cool
i liked my work most of the time but i
didn't love it
i searched and i searched but i just
could not find a software engineering
job
that i loved as much as i loved sailing
so i tried to create one
i put together a plan to start my own
company
that way i could completely control my
work environment
i would hire the most talented
programmers i knew
and we would all work together
on the most interesting and challenging
software projects
my group my goal was to create the
perfect job
for me
a job i truly loved
i never ex i never expected the company
to grow beyond 50 people when instead of
just holding on to all of the stock that
you got from yahoo
you did what
we call a collar you collared
so
you hedged it so tell everybody what
went through your mind because that was
a big bet with huge dollars right and it
was a pr it was actually pretty simple
so you know hedging stock if you know
yahoo paid us in yahoo stock
and
you know i
was smart enough to recognize i guess
that what goes up could go down but it
wasn't that big a step because i was
worth more than a billion dollars how
much did i need right so i was telling
everybody just find me a way to hedge it
so in the event look if the stock price
goes up and i leave something on the
table so be it right but
i like that being next to my name and i
wanted to keep it
and so
i sold calls bought puts and effectively
hedged it so that
by the time so
there was a period of time from when i'd
done that
and the internet stock market kept on
going up and and i told people i'd
hedged it and goldman sachs the company
had told people what i'd done and i
remember going on cnbc the business
channel and then the guy going boy don't
you feel stupid that yahoo stock has
kept on going up and you had this hedge
and i'm like yeah i feel so stupid
riding around my g5 that i bought online
you know
and and it was just like
not to sound like a crazy greasy greedy
capitalist but
yeah and it was like i just don't want
to screw it up and so i hedged it and
then the internet bubble burst and i was
fully protected and actually even made a
little bit more money and you know
middle um
you know the motto that the what i
learned was you just you don't need to
be greedy you know i was very very
blessed i was very fortunate look i
didn't plan the internet stock market to
go up and i didn't plan to go down so i
was lucky in terms of scale and i didn't
want to screw it up and so i had well if
you come up with an idea where you say i
can make dollar bills for 50 cents
would you go out and raise money or
would you just go out and sell it
you just go out and do it you know and
and that's what you have to do and look
we all go through that fear factor of do
i quit my job
do i can i do this
um
can i can i do this and what happens
next
the one thing i know with 100 certainty
and what i would tell myself is if i can
sell
and become a better and better
salesperson and be great at selling
i'm always going to be successful
whether i'm working for myself
or
if the company that i started just
didn't work i'll give you an example
out of indiana
before i went down to dallas i needed to
start something and um
i decided that
everybody drank milk
and i found this product powdered milk
that was cheaper and everybody needed to
save money
and i was going to go out there and sell
it
because it was cheaper now it didn't
taste quite as good
and so what i've but i went out there to
try to sell it
failed miserably but i learned
how to make the sales effort even when
things weren't going right i learned
that the rejection
was every no got me closer to a yes that
not every product was perfect but i
could take those same skills even in
failure
and translate them so that what i
learned selling garbage bags door to
door what i learned from selling
powdered milk that was awful what i
learned from selling local area networks
at micro solutions all those things
accumulated and i i got better at
selling so i always knew you know people
always say to me if you lost everything
what would you do
i can sell
i can sell and it's not about selling
ice to eskimos it's not about you know
convincing people to do this selling is
always about helping selling is always
about understanding the person you're
talking to and what their needs are and
if someone can help me
make my life easier
yeah people you know now with employees
people always say like
what's the definition of a great
employee
someone who can reduce the stress of
those around them
and it's the same thing what's the
definition of a great salesperson
someone who can reduce the stress of
their sales people and if in looking at
your company
and looking at your your life and
looking at your goals
if you're able to go out there and
recognize that
whether it works or doesn't work you're
putting yourself in a position where
you're helping somebody not convincing
somebody but and you're reducing their
stress
you're gonna you're gonna be okay it's
gonna work out and you know that's the
confidence i i've built in myself that
wasn't necessarily always there um
but i learned that if i try to help if i
reduce people's stress good things can
happen i actually think you should think
twice before starting certain types of
businesses so i think um there are
probably too many bad businesses getting
started and not enough good ones so
that's it's um you know i don't think
there's i don't think there's anything
about entrepreneurship per se
that is um
that is is good you know i was telling
one of my friends a few years ago i was
asking him what do you want to be doing
in five or ten years oh it's really
clear i want to be an entrepreneur
that's like saying i want to be rich i
want to be famous um and i i don't think
uh i don't think those are those are
good things being rich and famous um
they're not good as direct goals like if
you if you have that as your sole goal
you're unlikely to i think really
really succeed and so i think you become
an entrepreneur because you're working
on an important problem nobody else is
working on i think you should start a
business if you have
something if you're if you're working on
a problem that otherwise would not get
solved i have seen
people and
it happens to everybody no matter what
it is i've seen people rip you apart on
both sides
for both
how how does that
what what what
how does that drive you does that drive
you at all does that does that one
political correctness of having to
conform and being what everybody says
you're supposed to be
does that drive you at all
well it's it's uh you try you try to you
try to ignore it to some extent you know
you try um
not to um
but you don't you know you don't try to
um you don't try to put yourself into
any of these um very uncomfortable
straight jackets and you know you don't
want um and i think that's
that's what's so uh pernicious about all
the identity politics that uh that um
you know we we all have to be
in in this category we're all the same i
think people are all different we're all
you know we're all we're all you know
i'm somewhat idiosyncratic but i think
all of us are all of us are
idiosyncratic in different ways and i
think i think this is a this is
something that um most people experience
that they're being put into boxes way
more than they're comfortable you know
there's this interview question i always
like asking people tell me something
that's true that very few people agree
with you on
and um it's a very hard question to
answer
um and it's it's not because people
don't have answers they actually have
lots of answers to it it's because
they're uncomfortable answering it in
the context of an interview because um
you know if it has the answer has to be
something the person asking you won't
agree and we're always nervous about
doing that we always want to fit in and
this uh this this pressure to fit in is
uh
is is really powerful i don't think that
people burn out
i think it's impossible i'm not i'm not
a piece of wax i'm not a candle
so the burnout thing was put on us
by people that quit already yeah you're
gonna burn out dude you're gonna burn
out burnout is never about work nobody
burns out because they work too hard
oh you're burning the candle at both
ends i'm a spiritual being i create
energy this is a irresponsibility
like i've never met a human being that
was made of wax
you know oh yeah but you know i'm
burning in both ends you're you're a
being you're a being okay like quit
saying something's happening to you this
goes back to cause and effect i create
energy
and i love your example of the kids okay
that kid can play that game it's always
a game though yeah oh die or not it's
always a game
there's nothing that entertains people
more than a game
and so when i was
uh 18 years old man i was playing a game
called asteroids i would play i would
play
80 of it a day because it cost a quarter
every game right and i'm just piling
throwing them in doing anything i can to
get quarters so i can dump them into
this into this game
and i was trying to get to the next
level look at how people play candy
crush 700 levels and they're still
looking for the next level over and over
it's games
and that energy doesn't run out until
you hit boredom
because you can see a kid play a game
too long
and then they start getting like kind of
smashed in and their attitude gets bad
because they've been playing that same
game too long yeah
so i know that as long as i'm interested
not for me not passionate
for me
well for me for me i need to be able to
win at a game
if there's a chance i can win
i'll be excited about the game
if there's no chance to win i have no
interest
so for me for me the idea that i'm going
to follow my passions is a little bit
deluded for me i i think people are
looking for their passion i would not
follow my passion i would i would follow
the wins right so are you saying there's
things that you could really enjoy but
you don't think you could win is that
what you mean i i think if if
yeah i think that if you're
if there's no victory
the passion is is a little bit um
narcissistic
like oh i'm gonna i'm meant to be a
artist
baby ain't nobody buying your art
nobody's behind it all you do is
stacking art
okay who is so selfish
i do this for me
makes me feel good seven billion people
on this planet man like if you keep all
this to yourself sooner or later you're
still gonna look like a junkyard around
you
and at some point you're gonna see this
person cave in in depression and it's
like like where's the where's where
where where do you get the art out
like you know like i love watches right
mostly
so do i yeah most of my watches end up
on somebody else's arm yeah like i like
i have it for a while i love it for a
while and then i'm like here you have it
yeah and so for me like it needs to get
out and and um i have a victory in that
yeah i see it on somebody else's arm it
makes me happy yeah
and and so if if i write a book
and the book doesn't get sold i'm not
going to be excited about that book i
need the book in hands of other people
when i when you talk about women that's
not what i think about all right tell me
i don't think about the jet uh i mean i
think about my kids my wife all the time
i love my kids like
like oh my god man right the fact that
this guy lost his kid like like it's
just i know i know so anyway um
when i think about winning dude i don't
think about though i don't think about
stuff
i think about crushing people
okay i got a huge chip on my shoulder
nobody's ever asked me about it but it's
massive
my ship is like that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so tell me about it man why is that chip
so big
i don't know why don't that it doesn't
matter it served me so well that i'm not
you know you're just good with it
yeah i'm like let's roll you know
well because there's there's
stallone told me this too uh interviewed
stallone in california up in
san mateo
he's like got grant you got to have you
got got to have an adversary
he's like you look like one of those
guys it's like
he's like dude you're aggressive
i said bro you're rambo
right
yeah
he's not he's like not really really i'm
rocky
so so he's like my dark side's rambo got
it i said my lighter side is rainbow
right off
he's like hey you got to have an
adversary
he's like arnold arno he's like if it
wasn't for arnold grant i probably would
not be where i'm at
arnold was not a friend arnold was a
total adversary
got it repeated for roles
people compared us
you know so i've had a lot of that in my
career
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more amazing lessons from
billionaires check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there all these things are are very
risky
uh with a low chance of success but
if you want to try to come up with an
innovative breakthrough
that's kind of that's going to be how it
is